throwing household waste away in
Shanghai is a lot more complicated than
it used to be rubbish has to be sorted
into several categories including wet
and dry it's not optional it's an order
from the government and it seems to have
caught on quickly here the king hot this
garbage recycle Row is great for both
citizens and the country we're used to
it already it's no trouble for us at all
like when I'm cooking I automatically
separate the kitchen waste and other
wastes it's a habit now at set times
people take their separated wastes to
bins that have been placed in
communities around the city the contents
are then collected and taken for
recycling composting or incineration for
power generation businesses also have to
abide by the new laws if they don't they
could be fined up to seventy thousand
dollars the motivation behind a program
like this would be applauded by most but
there is also a sense that the
government has missed a step out and
that not enough emphasis is being placed
on educating people how to reduce waste
in the first place
in 2014 China declared war on pollution
that's made significant gains
particularly with air pollution but with
rapid economic expansion came a boom in
consumerism the growing waste problem
which is the government's next target it
wants a standardized nationwide rubbish
sorting system to be in place in the
next six years and Shanghai is seen as
the big test the city's residents
produce more than twenty two thousand
tons of waste per day among the
contributors is China's growing love
affair with food delivery services which
is now a seventy billion dollar industry
experts agree that education could be
improved but the new initiative is a
significant step China is still coming
out from a culture where people I still
don't see littering on the streets as an
offense so going from like littering on
the streets to literally putting stuff
in the bin but in the right bin that's
that's a big jump for for people right
now
the test will be when the novelty wears
off and the volunteers keeping an eye on
the process and no longer there for now
the government is serious about tackling
China's waste problem and people have no
choice but to follow the law
Wayne hey al-jazeera Shanghai